c'est l'info insolite de la semaine de
la sorcellerie aurait été utilisée dans
la télé réalité
moi je reste perplexe on sait car la
mort ou une candidate de l'émission les
marseillais qui auraient contacté une
voyante dans le but de jeter un sort à
maeva gay nam son ex meilleure amie
pourquoi tu fais ça c'est certain pour
ce que la sorcellerie est une invention
de charlatans autres y croit dur comme
fer et sont persuadés que cela
fonctionne
la sorcellerie est un art qui se base
sur des forces surnaturelles et des
entités maléfiques pour modifier le
destin par le prisme de la magie
certains sorts sont envoyés pour nuire à
des tiers comme ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine dans la sphère des marseillais
on parle alors de magie noire et sort
qu'il serait très difficile de contrer
qui pourrait avoir de lourdes
conséquences dans d'autres cas il serait
possible de souhaiter du bien son
entourage à des fins altruiste et
bienveillante des sorts affiliés cette
fois ci à la magie blanche
alors faut-il vraiment avoir peur de la
sorcellerie ou bas taton buzzer dès que
tu t'en en bout balech tu peux buzz et
voilà faut-il avoir peur la sorcellerie
bonsoir merci sarah d'être là alors vous
êtes assez la sorcière oui oui c'est la
cca alors vous êtes suivi par 600 mille
personnes sur tik tok cette affaire de
sorcellerie dans des marseillais a fait
beaucoup parler est ce que ça existe ça
c'est ça dépend des croyances de chacun
moi forcément je veux dire que ça existe
et on aime ça dure on peut jeter des
sorts à quelqu'un selon moi oui oui oui
ah ouais c'est des pratiques qui sont
quand même qu'ils sont révélateurs
répertoriés depuis des millénaires
ça a toujours existé dans toutes les
croyances et les pratiques des
différents pays donc c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
responsable ce depuis vraiment longtemps
et htc à faire mieux ici tes skis ben tu
vois que des noms nous n'avons pas un
seul n'a pas peur des sorcières pourquoi
tu crois toi tu croitoru binger koutaba
oui alors et vous quel panier dit que
c'est vrai
gilbert bel et bien sûr que c'est vrai
on peut jeter des sorts en france
notamment par la nourriture par la
boisson par les cheveux aussi les
cheveux de femme notamment bien sûr les
cheveux des femmes
on peut faire des tas de choses
négatives moi je connais peu plus les
choses négatives par les cheveux des
femmes
ah bah ça se voit j'ai vu aussi
dans les caraïbes enterré des autres
poulets pour détruire des gens donc bien
sûr que la source était existe mais bien
sûr bien sûr un bidon que vous n'y
croyez pas ce que vous avez et
rationnelle et bien sûr ils ont tiré des
autres les autres blessés xix cette
histoire c'est vrai que c'est quand même
des pratiques bien pire que ça oui
pierre ben oui c'est surtout avec les
bébés est face à moi alors c'est quoi
l'histoire et surtout aussi avec les
poupées on peut en sauce et les des gens
et moi j'ai les petites astuces quand
même pour pour envoyée pour effacer ccc
sort justement c'est quoi c'est bon tu
sais si tu seras sortant déjà une fois
par semaine vous prenez un bain mais
vraiment réel avec du sel in à maillas
et du sel rose qu'ensuite ce qui est
important moi je sais c'est important
c'est les petites pierres là c'est
l'oeil du tigre
çà çà çà vous protège aussi contre les
mauvais sorts important de nettoyer ce
hors saison c'est un truc de ouf l1 je
te le dis ouah elles sont les choses à
la fois c'est très important de nettoyer
sa maison aussi avec de la sauge en
tournant dans l'est dans l'eau mais dans
cette histoire j'ai un nom mais comme
vous voulez avec une prière que vous
soyez juifs
catholique n'importe quel mais que vous
ressentez hier très fort vous faites une
prière c'est super important quand vous
avez trop de merde dans la maison sous
vos fenêtres vous mettez des petits bols
de sel à chaque ouverture de chez vous
et ensuite trois jours après vous
ramasser tout fait couler sous le choc
c'est super important quand t'as pas
d'emploi et sans emploi il faut il faut
savoir qu'il faut jamais montré ses
faiblesses faut montrer qu'on est en
forme parce que plus on est fatigué ah
ouais plus on peut atteindre la personne
donc c'est important de se nettoyer
avoir plein d'énergie sur soit sa race
et or est ce qu a dit loeb en a c'est
vrai mais par contre il faut pas résumer
la sorcellerie a uniquement la magie
noire 1,5 ya énormément de pratiques
différentes il ya tout ce qu'on appelle
la magie vert de la magie rouge la magie
mais la magie garde ses skis et c'est la
magie qui utilise les plantes oui ça
existe
ah ouais c'est vrai ouais c'est ça c'est
dans l'ain par un peu de magie mais
c'est blake est souvent faite par
apporter les personnes qui sont dans
dans l'ésotérisme à la drogue mais pas
du tout voilà mais dans la mégère c'est
tout ce qui est utilisée énergie de la
nature il est donc c'est fou non mais
moi je savais pas et donc on peut
envoyer des talibés tout de suite y
croit ça ou pas de toi tu es cartésien
toi qui t'y crois pas moi j'ai déjà
enterré des oeufs dans le sable au
sénégal ah ouais les dessins dessus j'ai
déjà fait des trucs ne sait jamais sur
un malentendu
oui exactement c'est pas ça a échoué
mais jamais chez que ça existe oui ça
marche mais c'étaient des eaux offensif
ou des autres protections pour le
blogueur quelqu'un cela dit les oeufs
c'est très très grave
coiffure ah oui c'est très très vieux
poisson la ccc comme le pouvoir de
l'intention
la pensée positive pour soi même on peut
se faire de la magie par exemple on
visualise le soir avant de s'endormir
quelque chose pendant que tu dois
réaliser dans notre vie hein c'est pas
de la magie ça la magie la magie c'est
de la motivation
oui non la magie c'est l'art de faire
circuler l'énergie en fait il peut y
avoir de la magie blanche qu'on peut
envoyer quelques en faisant des prières
en le pensant en bonne santé et la magie
noire effectivement et pendant magie
noire revient à celui qui l'envoie ces
saboteurs pas toujours ah ouais c'est à
dire toujours y aller il ya des saars
aux tons sourds solide oui moi est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il ya des preuves
oui c'est l'épreuve alors de passer la
dernière partie les résultats d'autres
cas des bâillons se dit oui il ya eu un
truc côté preuve il ya des on peut
toujours apporter des cas où il ya eu
des résultats après des sortilèges après
c'est vrai qu'on peut toujours dire que
des sources pourquoi mais des preuves au
japon mais il ya des preuves ya eu des
expériences ya eu des cas où il ya des
choses qui se sont passées après ce que
c'est des preuves scientifiques n'ont
jamais été prouvé scientifiquement sinon
ce serait une science ça c'est sûr mais
bon après il ya eu des résultats
certaines choses est ce que c'est une
coïncidence ou pas voilà quoi mais c'est
vrai que moi qui ai tout le temps des
coïncidences à chaque fois donc en fait
il a jamais eu un truc quoi tiens à vous
dire c'est je comprends ces jours on a
jeté un sort à quelqu'un le lendemain la
meute qui m'a dit merci d'avoir été là
c'est cruel